we've been using the cosine rule for
fighting legs we're now going to be
forward and we're going to use it for
finding angles pretty good so you
haven't copied this new blue diagram
down please do so just like this line
rule can be used for lengths and it can
be used for angles right I can use the
cursor room for both sides of the
equation okay how am I going to do it
I'm going to just write down my cosine
rule again because you can see this
equation it's geared to find a side
right I have the side here is the
subject and that's why it was so easy to
find out right of every formula is
geared to find something for instance um
you guys recognize this what's this our
formula for this is the area of a circle
right so this is geared to find the area
if you know the radius okay but I could
merely easily just put this around the
other way suppose I knew what the area
of my circle is but I want to find the
radius what I do to this guy I would
make our the subject I suppose I would
put the PI over here I'm gonna do one
more thing what would I do from there I
would take the square root right so I'm
going to go put the arm over here square
root now usually when i take the square
root of both sides now usually have to
worry about awesome itís i throw it in
this particular case can anyone tell me
why just a little side note yeah very
good for the same reason that this here
i'd have to worry about a plus or minus
it's because this length has to be
positive can't possibly be negative so
that's why that's why I just had a
possible cost minus here same deal here
right so this changing the subject
business right now if I know what the
area of a circle is like if I've
measured out you know the number of
squares on a leading panel something
like that I / piatek square root now
don't give me the radius that's not
changing the subject does so let's play
this game with the cosine rule
this is how we've been writing the
coastline it's geared to find a side
right so you can see there's an angle
hiding in there right the ankle is over
there right in the very end of the
equation capital C that's the angle i
want okay so what I'm going to do is I
want to rearrange everything just like I
rearrange it here so the angle is and we
you know the college see we have on the
left hand side of everything else we on
the right so let's start rearranging the
star does not object is I'm going to put
this C squared and there's minus 12 is
too costly I'm going to swap them around
swap them around so I'm going to get to
a because C and I'm going to get a
squared plus B so everybody see screen
on the right so I've literally just
swapped them I've added to a because C
to both sides and I've taken away c
squared from both sides okay so far so
good only one more step I need to do now
to get the angle by itself right I just
need to get rid of this pesky to a B
which is hanging there on the left so
i'll divide everything through divide
both sides by 2 ay B okay so that's
going to leave you with this on the
right hand side okay so let's just pause
for a second what we've just written
down is still the cosine rule I started
from the same spot this is the cosine
rule and this last line is also because
only and you can use both it depends on
what you want to find here I wanted to
find a side so it made sense to use that
first one but now I want to find an
angle so it makes you sense to use this
second one okay so let's give it a go on
this particular question right I've got
the formula written down I've got my
diagram and now I just want to interpret
it properly so i know what to fit we're
okay what's the name of the unknown
angle i want to find let's just meet up
so i'm going to go directly from here
right I can speed up now be careful over
here on the right hand side I've got a a
B and C right now a and B you can swap
them around if you like and it's all the
same right like a squared plus B squared
is the same as b squared 4a squared so
it doesn't matter if you switch them
around but c c does matter can you see
why it matter if we're doing something
different to see right so therefore i
have to know which one c is and put in
the right spot how do I know which one
seems its opposite remember we said just
to make sure these are consistent if you
label a corner capital C we tend to
label the opposite side lower case e you
see that okay just to see just to make
it easy for us to work out what is where
okay so you can see conventions are not
just because oh we did it this way
because that's a tradition we always do
it that way actually makes things easier
right so six and seven them a and b six
and seven right and then what's left
over is that opposite side okay then on
the bottom I've survived the a and the
beaters to six and seven done okay so
now again I've gotten to that point
where I've interpreted correctly and now
I've got to do a bit of none number
cruncher so let's get a decimal out of
this cos beta can someone give me maybe
three or four decimal places someone is
already calculated that fraction on the
right anyone there can I get some
verification yeah does that send bye-bye
perfect ok so now remember when I use
the same rule to find angles I get to a
similar point except that have sine
theta equals this so what am I going to
do my calculator to just get theta yeah
I'm going to go that shift cause which
is cause the major one that's all looks
like cos inverse okay and that will hand
me an angle okay uh let's just do it to
the nearest degree shall we
for the sake of it we don't need to
worry about approximation what do I get
44 degrees for to the nearest you know
okay let's just pause from it before we
leave this does it make sense look
reasonable I think it looks reasonable
44 degrees you notice out of 5 6 and 7
from the sine rule we ought to expect
that this is the smallest angle in the
triangle does that make sense it's the
smallest angle because it's opposite the
smaller side okay so 44 degrees yeah
I've got room in there to make some big
angle this makes sense now one more
thing I want to ask is in the sine rule
I had this ambiguous case if I'm finding
an angle it could be this or it could be
that have a brilliant thing about cosine
rule is there's no ambiguity but the
question is why why does the sine rule
leave us with the question now we have
to do that thing with the angle song and
the cosine one doesn't yeah
okay so there's two reasons the first
one is what Arians vision right do you
remember what I said before there's our
for tests for Congress for triangle
congruence remember that okay let's just
quickly rehearse what the four tests are
just give me one anyone SSS give me
another one someone else SAS another one
rhs that's the history of the group no
one ever uses him and there's this one
more it's like that it's a a s okay now
we've got these four tests i pointed out
that with the same old you've got this
situation right and the angle is in the
wrong spot look at the angles in the
wrong spot okay you don't actually know
if the train was a call girl or not okay
so there's a pair of triangles that
could both be there that the same angle
same side same side but they're not
actually the same triangle which is why
you could get for instance if you had if
you use the sine rule and you've got 30
degrees it could be 150 right there are
two possible train was that fit back how
do I look at this triangle over on the
right hand side we're using the cosine
rule what information when you're trying
to find angle what information is the
cosine will need it needs needs more
than that doesn't it it needs all three
sides to do the cosine did you see that
right I've got the angle here on the
Left which I don't know and then what I
do know is a and B and C I need all
three sides if I took this guy out
you're stuck you actually can't find at
least on this information you can't find
out what that angle it's been certainty
okay but we do know now I want you to
look back again at these kolgrim's proof
right which conference proof does the
cosine will correspond to it's it's one
side two sides three sides right it's
the top line it's the top one now
there's no way like if you've got all
three sides you've got all three sides
you absolutely have to have the same
triangle they have to be congruent
there's no way you can accidentally get
the wrong one right and end up with two
solutions so there's the first reason I
have all three sides right if I gave you
guys all
you guys like pipe cleaners right those
are things you can bend around let me
just make crafts out of them if i gave
you a pipe cleaners one of them was five
centimeters one we're 61 was seven and I
gave you guys 30 sets and I said all of
you make a triangle okay you're all
going to make exactly the same triangle
there's no way you can make another one
they're all going to be congruent so
this is the first reason the second
reason I looks like this still here you
remember what the sine curve looks like
right what the sake of looks like it
looks like this like so so when you look
up to this point and you wanted to solve
this you'd say sine theta equals
something you go across and you found
one two solutions right and there's your
ambiguity okay what does cosine look it
looks like this right now your
calculator isn't telling you but it's
actually not looking at the whole rap
it's only looking at half of it okay so
when you draw across your same line the
cards right 0.71 for I don't know
something like that okay you're only
going to get one solution that guy there
okay so because the shape of cosine is
different you get a better result
there's no ambiguity with it okay if
you're finding an angle or you're
fighting aside the cosine rule is
generally about a sort of a choice
that's the one that you use on any
questions
one last point up before I shut up and
get out of your way okay remember I keep
saying the cosine rule i think the
easiest way to help you remember it is
to think Pythagoras think Pythagoras
okay I think Pythagoras knew that the
cosine rule works and here's how I
reckon he knew I want you to imagine
right if I have a right angle triangle
like wow I don't have much space line
like this okay and see capital C right
is the angle opposite what side is this
in a right angle train move that's
usually the hypotenuse alright so here
is the hypotenuse I don't care whether I
pull this aw you're being a okay so
which angle here is capital C it's look
it's the right angle isn't it okay now
you're going to risk your calculator I
feel really good you might remember
what's cause of a right angle what's
caused 19 Cosmo TV learning or actually
have it right here cause 90 it's zero
you can check it in your calculator if
you like cause mine is there or I can go
to the unit circle go to the unit circle
90 degrees is all the way up here right
and close is the x-coordinate of that
spot just which is 0 right so close 90
this part becomes zero in a right angle
triangle this to a because e-business it
disappears off and brilliantly
beautifully it leaves you with
Pythagoras theorem okay so the cosine
rule it really is it's not just the
coincidence that looks like Pythagoras
it's Pythagoras and it works for all
different triangles even 90 degree was
okay